bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle édition du 78 lactus
de ce vendredi 14 mars comme tous les
jours vous le savez nous allons faire le
point sur votre actualité locale tout
d'abord cette information vous le savez
en raison de l'épisode de pollution de
ces 8 derniers jours le président du
Syndicat des transports d'île-de-fancean
Paul Huchon a annoncé hier la gratuité
des transports en commun à partir de ce
vendredi matin et ce jusqu'à dimanche
soir cette décision pourrait même durer
jusqu'à la fin du pic de pollution à
noter que le seuil d'alerte est dépassé
depuis 3 jours et si la situation ne
s'améliore pas sur la région de
nouvelles mesures pourrai être envisagé
a indiqué le ministre de l'écologie
Philippe Martin comme la circulation
alternée depuis ce vendredi matin la
préfecture des Yvelines a notamment mise
en place de nouvelles limitations de
vitesse sur les axes routiers du
département aux alentours de 20 kmh en
dessous de la moyenne habituelle donc
par exemple sur les autoroutes vous
devrez rouler à 110 au lieu des 130 km/h
habituels en politique nous continuons
vous le savez notre tour d'horizon des
candidats aux élection municipale cette
année au clé sousbois quatre listes
s'affronteront pour la mairie le 23 mars
prochain claire Cambier vous présente
les
candidat aux clés sousbois la mère
Véronique éillard se présente à sa
propre session en poste depuis 2001
après avoir ravi la ville au parti
communiste l'élu udi souhaite poursuivre
ses projets ses priorité l'emploi et le
logement nous avons eu la chance d'avoir
avec les nouveaux centres commerciaux
donc des créations d'emploi avec le
projet de pisalou pourrait être créé
2000 emplois ce qui est extrêmement
important surtout dans le le monde
actuel et le logement c'est-à-dire
continuer ce qu'on a commencé à faire la
mixité sociale des petites unités dans
lequel vous avez de l'accession sociale
à la propriété vous avez du locatif
social et vous avez du logement privé et
les constructions qui sont autour de
nous en sont un exemple autre projet un
centre d'accueil pour enfants ou le
développement du centre ville et de
Sahal cette mère de famille de 55 ans
l'annonce déjà il s'agira de son dernier
mandat habitante de la commune depuis 25
ans elle a commencé sa carrière
politique en participant au Conseil
municipaux avant de se voir proposer de
mener une liste d'opposition face au
maire communiste en 19 95 face à elle
son éternel adversaire Jean-Michel
Gourdon et lu municipal d'opposition est
déjà candidat en 2008 une de ses
priorités la fiscalité nous sommes une
ville qui a subi une augmentation des
impôts ces dernières
années de l'ordre de 24 % sur les 6
dernières années donc c'est quelque
chose qui revient assez régulièrement le
logement aussi un grand souci la ville
d'éclé est une ville qui où la moyen
d'âge augmente d'année en année et
l'écléiens ont
sont très inquiets de voir que leurs
enfants ne pourront certainement pas se
loger non pas parce qu'il n'y a pas de
construction mais tout simplement parce
que le prix des logements produit est
trop élevé autre projet repenser le
stationnement pour développer le
commerce de proximité et développer
transport en commun et circulation douce
à 60 ans ce père de 5 enfants n'est pas
novice en politique natif des clés il
est depuis une dizaine d'années
conseiller général des ivelines mais
liste de Jean-Michel Gourdon ne sera pas
la seule liste de gauche en opposition
avec la politique du gouvernement
Olivier Augustin 50 ans candidat de
Lutte ouvrière n'a pas voulu s'allier
avec le candidat socialiste il a donc
monté sa propre liste sa priorité
l'emploi il souhaite surtout porter la
voix des travailleurs plutôt que de
proposer une politique locale il
soutient l'idée d'une interdiction des
licenciement pour les entreprises mesure
phare de son parti né au clé sous bois
il travaille actuellement comme ouvrier
dans une usine automobile de Flin il
regrette l'évolution de sa commune ces
dernières années aujourd'hui quand on
est salarié vivre au cl sou bois ça
devient de plus en plus difficile parce
que tout tout devient très cher et les
gens bah maintenant on est obligé de de
fuir même ces coins là pour essayer de
soit de d'avoir un loyer ou les plus
chanceux d'accéder à la propriété
quelque part et mais ça ça devient de
plus en plus difficile et ça c'est c'est
c'est regrettable parce que aujourd'hui
des communes comme ça ça doit rester
populaire
dernier candidat à se présenter Claude
debouer Le pidi avocat et conseiller
municipal depuis une dizaine d'années il
a monté sa liste à quelques jours
seulement du dépôt légal cet homme de 56
ans réside dans la commune depuis près
de 40 ans son objectif dépasser les
cllivage politique et laisser une plus
large place à la démocratie
participative la richesse d'un pays la
richesse d'une démocratie c'est de
mettre à la table tous les gens tous les
citoyens quel que soit leur conviction
politique qui disent je taie ma passion
politique mon mon mon engagement
politique et je suis capable de
travailler dans un sens de l'ouverture
constructif pour réaliser des projets en
commun c'est ça la démocratie si dans le
casre de cette campagne on parvient à
réaliser à faire comprendre aux hommes
politiques cet objectif là et bien quel
que soit les urn on aura gagné quel que
soit le choix des yeux on en aura gagné
il ne lui reste plus que quelques jours
pour faire campagne parmi ses priorités
une pause de l'augmentation des impôts
locaux la baisse du coût du logement ou
encore l'accent sur la préservation de
l'environnement au clés sous-bois on
comptabilise donc aujourd'hui quatre
candidats tous déjà impliqués dans la
vie locale les cléciens ont jusqu'au 23
mars pour faire leur choix pour l'avenir
de leur
ville place désormais à notre page
spéciale éducation créé il y a 1 an le
mouvement des gilets jaunes composés
notamment de parents d'élèves et de
professeurs de l'éducation nationale
continue de protester contre contre la
réforme des rythmes scolaires à la
veille d'une manifestation de grande
ampleur à Paris Florence jacome
coordinatrice du mouvement dans lesin M
rejoint sur ce plateau bonjour à vous
merci d'être là tout
d'abord tout d'abord première question
concrètement ce weekend vous allez donc
manifester contre cette réforme et vous
demandez tout simplement l'abrogation de
la réforme payant c'est ça
expliquez-nous pourquoi
alors on demande l'abrogation de cette
réforme car elle a elle a été euh mise
en place sans concertation avec les
différents acteurs on a on observe sur
les les communes qui l'ont misise en
place actuellement des
dysfonctionnements
euh des inégalités entre les différentes
communes euh une inégalité publque
privée puisque l'école privée n'est pas
obligée de de l'appliquer euh des
difficultés pour recruter des des
animateurs des soucis au niveau des des
locaux parce que pour proposer des
activités aux enfants avec des taux
d'encadrement correct il faut des locaux
en nombre suffisant à l'heure actuelle
on a aucune idée du coût réel de cette
réforme on a un souci au niveau des
maternelles qui ne peuvent pas avoir le
même rythme que les primaires
donc pour les maternel reprendre l'école
à 14h c'est compliqué parce qu'ils ont
besoin de faire une sieste après la
rentrée scolaire donc de 2013 20 % des
écoles ont adopté la réforme vous
trouvez justement ce mouvement des Gets
jaunes trouveent que ce n'est pas
efficace en tout cas dans l'ensemble
c'est ça euh pas efficace
euh j'aurais pas dit ça comme ça euh je
suis désolée je suis voilà je vous avais
dit que j'aurais du mal c'est un store
c'est pas grave c'est un store en tout
cas vous me disiez quand on prépar
l'émission pour vous une école à deux
vitesses vous parliez de ce privé
justement qui n'est pas oigé je oui tout
à fait et je je trouve que Ben en
l'école doit doit être égale doit être
accessible à tous doit être gratuite et
là on se dirige vers une école à deux
vitesses donc une grosse différence
entre le public et le privé autour de
moi j'entends beaucoup de parents me
dire bah on va en mettre dans le privé
pour ceux qui qui ont les moyens euh et
puis d'une commune à l'autre il y a des
communes qui pourront proposer des
activités intéressantes aux enfants et
d'autres qui feront
du coloriage ou qui joue de la
garderie pas forcément animé avec des
gens compétents qui sont aptes à garder
les enfants dans dans de bonnes
conditions ce sera peut-être le cas de
de votre commune vous je le rappelle
vous êtes habitante de richbourg une
commune ivelinoise de un petit peu plus
de 1500 habitants et là vous pensez que
dans votre ville justement il pourrait y
avoir ces problème de structure
d'animateur alors à l'heure actuelle
dans notre commune nous n notre commune
fait partie d'une communauté de communes
de 37
communes la communauté a voté une motion
demandant le report de de cette réforme
euh il faut savoir que sur 37 communes
nous n'avons que neuf centres de loisirs
donc des des difficultés pour accueillir
les enfants si toutes les écoles n'ont
pas les mêmes horaires euh des coûts
supplémentaire de transport en commun à
mettre en
placeun voilà entre les communes pour
ramener les enfants dans les centres
après l'école le mercredi matin
euh voilà j'ai encore perdu mon fil
alors par rapport à ce mouvement des
gilets jaunes vous je le disais tout à
l'heure ça a été créé il y a un an à peu
près vous n'avez pas peur que cette
manifestation de demain ce samedi 15
mars soit pas un peu trop tardive parce
que bah la réforme est en route quand
même non euh ben je je non je pense que
oui ça aurait été bien peut-être de de
de de manifester dès la mise en place
enfin dès
à partir du moment où le décret a été
voté mais je pense qu'il est jamais trop
tard pour bien faire et que quand on on
fait des erreurs c'est important de de
rectifier et de d'essayer d'aller dans
le bon chemin et là je pense que
vraiment on s'éloigne je pense qu'on va
pas vers le le bien de l'enfant et c'est
ce qui m'ennuie alors votre association
votre mouvement se structure via
notamment une page sur les réseaux
sociaux où il y a 48000 j'aes c'est
plutôt
important pour une page fan comme on dit
sur internet mais est-ce que c'est assez
rassembleur en tout cas est-ce que vous
avez vous pensez qu'il y aura assez de
monde demain à Paris pour pour marcher
alors j'ai pas j'ai pas le don
d'ubiquité de savoir combien nous serons
demain c'est très difficile
d'évaluer la mobilisation des
parents il y a des décisions qui se
prennent en dernières minutes ah bah
finalement je vais y aller donc on sait
nous pertinemment que énormément de
parents sont contre euh des professeurs
des écoles qui viendront euh demain
manifester sans appel forcément de de
leur syndicat des animateurs euh donc on
sait vraiment que la la la motivation
l'opposition est est réelle euh bon
après est-ce que les gens viendront
demain à Paris on l'espère et et voilà
il fera beau les transports sont
gratuits donc on invite tout le monde à
venir
manifester à cette réforme donc vous
vous demandez l'abrogation mais est-ce
que vous pensez tout de même qu'il faut
réformer le système de l'éducation
nationale alors actu on n'est pas du
tout à dire que l'école doit rester
comme elle est elle doit évoluer on fait
effectivement des constats que les les
résultats ne sont pas forcément bons en
sortie de primaire mais je suis pas
persuadée que c'est d'essayer
d'installer des des cours de théâtre ou
de coloriage qui vont améliorer les Ch
améliorer les choses euh je je pense
pense que peut-être revoir les
programmes alléger les classes enfin
voilà il a il y a peut-être d'autres
choses à faire avant de de vouloir faire
une grande réforme
globale tout n'est pas mauvais mais elle
n'est pas bien pensé dernière question
les gilet jaune c'est votre nom vous en
portez un le symbole de ce gilet jaune
euh et bien c'est pour la sécurité des
enfants le le le gilet jaune a été a
commencé à être porté parce qu'on a
retrouvé des enfants dans la rue suite à
la en place de la réforme et au nombreux
dysfonctionnement où les les animateurs
enfin les les personnes qui devaient
garder les enfants ne savaient pas
forcément quel groupe d'enfants il
devait avoir il y a eu des choses assez
cocasses des enfants qui font de l'AS
mais les animateur n'avait pas les pai
oui voilà très bien merci beaucoup
Florent jacom d'être passé sur le 78
lactu et donc rendez-vous pour ceux qui
le souhaite demain ce samedi à partir de
15h à Paris pour manifester contre cette
réforme payon merci beaucoup à vous
merci une dernière information avant de
nous quitter dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi aux alentours de 4h du matin 5
cambriour roumain âgé de 22 à 32 ans ont
été interpellés att trrape avec près
d'une tonne de cuivre dérobé dans
l'enceinte d'une société de Limet le
gérant de cette entreprise a évidemment
été prévenu les cinq suspects ont été
placés en garde à vue au commissariat de
trappe c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas vos idées
de sortie avec Torz et le 78 weekend
quant à moi je vous souhaite un
excellent weekend sur TV
fil